[Music]
in equality wins news I hate equality
it's it's shame when women rule and what
about gender equality okay you like it
when white people rule and everyone else
drools about racial equality or do you
like it what poor people or rich people
could nice ISM no one doesn't happen
ever hey I'm dude my bad I didn't
anything about that submitted by I heart
boobies shame I hope he's doing this not
me
hey Tess yeah give me a flat chested
flat butt girl that just looks like so
flat that when she goes this way she
disappears you do you man yeah
hashtag free the nipple wins victory in
Colorado I say good
why is Colorado a red stay and it's all
acting like a blue state now I was like
didn't they legalize weed and everything
yeah [ __ ] cuz he see the dollar sign hey
oh yes undetectable California was took
a long time and what a blue state do
California sucks with that I say you
guys go to Vegas know you know do you
that was just mean-spirited you said you
wanted to come support even our jury you
know that I want to go to Vegas and
you're single-handedly hyped it up to
the whole team that we had all go to
Vegas and then you single-handedly
destroy the dream wait a minute wait a
minute a weekend you bought a house I
could sublet easily not dream I didn't
she ruined it may butter they bought
recent from I didn't like it because geo
was telling me to go back to where I
came from the casino
oh the Commerce Casino you like it I
know well you know I can't get away yeah
I'll probably die I'm like too early of
a lifetime if I do that okay we're not
letting you go to Vegas now that you're
single let's go to like [ __ ] one of
the casinos bro like legit yeah let's go
let's do it I just got back from Vegas
but let's go again what what's the one
in Palm Springs you're not no no I'm
talking about here
a ton of them Pachanga Morongo morongo I
was texting you guys was there Marah
goes the one to go to if you want to see
sorrows you want to see some sorrows
agua caliente really bad there you got
to go to the really shitty ones words
that's supposed to be like nice and [ __ ]
no dude I was that morongo real quickly
I was a trongo
this cat was playing video poker I
always the one I don't play the only one
at home blip
thank you wait video roulette right and
he's sitting there and he's his agent
guy I only say that so you can visualize
it with me okay
you see ethnicities thank you and so he
sat there and this cat he pushed chips
on every single number on man every
single number he puts in $235 as soon as
he sits down he then proceeds to hit
every single [ __ ] number except for
like three in the middle okay single
time but he wins like maybe thirty seven
dollars but then he bet like 75 yeah I
was gonna say like did you have the
heart to tell him like that's not how
the odds on this game work I'm there to
watch off your bet against yourself
people don't all that sometimes it's
like I'm a documentary filmmaker and I'm
filming march of the Penguins and I see
a penguin in the snow I can't pick it up
I can't you know yeah he's got a dust
observe nature at work so then so then
he loses his entire $235 in six minutes
and he stands up like she he stands up
like he just was in pain he's like
that's so dumb cuz that deaf bucking
guys like throwing money into a pond
right he doesn't know what he's doing
couldn't wait to tell you this cuz you I
wish you could have seen him hit every
single number of methodically like he
had a system I don't know if I have the
heart for that kind of sad this you want
to stop them you would have been like
hey you know I walked away live did you
ever go to 7-eleven you watched a guy
buy like [ __ ] $60 and sorry I've got
my favorite things to do
mr. Brell I just sit there with a
Slurpee okay I want to hear this
yeah cuz I'm like when can i sorry I'm
sorry alright so this story here it was
so this story here it all started in
Fort Collins Colorado it's really hard
for me to enunciate right now okay so
they so there was this group of women
who say that their right to wear or not
wear a shirt is a big deal and they
would like to have the right to take off
their shirts if they want to just like
the boys I agree yeah yeah yeah let's
see him do we have the right to watch
yeah not creepingly both my colleague
did well that's [ __ ] creepy that's
creepy how about like this more creepy
how about like this less creepy that's
the way you should look listen boy I
love all the chitlins so oh that guy
bridge guys I could see here oh yeah
epic music to her ears I wanna play - a
huge play fun kill know you you're
playful so the these group of women so
one of them her name is Britt she said
addressing small parts of inequality can
make a big difference in how people are
treated on a day to day basis and I
thought free the nipple was just one
small step closer to how it should be so
what happened here is that they went to
court they sued the city of Fort Collins
for the right to pass a law to go
topless in public and so they ended up
winning yeah because they're saying that
it's unconstitutional to say that women
can't do a certain thing just because of
their
gender yeah when they win do they go
like in court what about us like can we
walk around with no pants man hold on so
Ben they say we get privileged and they
say we have privilege I don't think they
got to the trousers yet so after the
courts ruled in favor of the the girls
that's when the city appealed to the
federal Tenth Circuit of Appeals and
they also ruled the in favor of the
topless women Wow
which means a lot of horny guys Fort
Collins gets to have like women get to
free the nipple also color like all of
Colorado Wyoming Utah New Mexico and
Kansas and Oklahoma yeah because of the
fact that the city took it up to a
higher court which covered those 60 and
this is only for hot chicks right I hope
so
cuz usually when you go to the nude
beach it's all these old [ __ ] that I
don't want to see naked pancakes it's
never the goo that you want to see naked
and pancake mile waffle acids chicks how
do you guys feel about it because I
think for guys it's like of course you
want to see a more nipple and it's not
even our body so we don't really care
how do you chicks feel the bank it's
about this new law I would love to take
my shirt off and just be like just
[ __ ] free the titties so you would
want all these states to pass this yeah
I think it's done I would only do it if
it's the norm not if it's like I'm not
gonna be an early adopter in this so you
don't want to see a guy go like this
well definitely because it's early there
but let them get desensitized to it and
now they're like oh god cities of
titties might take some years though
yeah it might take something so you know
think so good look at look at Europeans
like beaches and [ __ ] they're always
topless I don't think eyes like how long
have they had like those laws that
and they see in commercials and [ __ ]
they see tens everywhere right so we
need to get their bicep and then not
only that like it but you're right I
think we could get desensitized sooner
because even just going to a strip club
after like a few minutes there I'm go
I'm tired of titties Sam yeah everywhere
let's do it I feel I've been fast I see
people tattoos and get scared and now I
want to tattoo so let's do it I want it
done then I want to stay Oni we're doing
it I will say that you don't show me
your teeth you do need early adopters in
order to move the ball and I'm like I
support you later I get a point I'm not
good it's all the grandmas and the ones
you don't want to see you know it's [ __ ]
to dye their armpit hair blue and
gentlemen doing it for you guys so I
don't care I still have to look at it
blue
no it's boy oh it's [ __ ] catches your
eyes candy is trapped under her [ __ ]
arm pain go up there and eat it oh
that's oddly just like armpit the color
didn't change it Nikki one time posted a
bunch of pics of chicks with excessive
body hair on her on her Instagram as a
pit and I was like I almost unfollowed
you today why would she do such a thing
it was so repulsive I've never been more
disgusted that should be a longer
there's a law for you know are you know
there is a genre but boys no I I think
it's gross on both but I don't look at
guys like do you shave your own pit [ __ ]
no so would you but look nobody looks at
guys and goes like oh yeah whatever
[ __ ] oh yeah like that armpit hair
there are girls that love and Harryman
arm yes there's also women that don't
lot of fitness dude shave their armpits
you shave your feet know I feel weird if
I did I'm like one of the only ones
mostly 99% of fitness dudes all shave
there I'm glad yeah I still feel without
the I'm old-fashioned I still feel weird
about it leave a normal startin a
doesn't have harm air and he's older
than me he doesn't have it he shaves it
companies only usually he's a pro
bodybuilder like since be like some
Yukon [ __ ] whiskey yes mom I don't
want girls to show their boobs anymore
too late if anybody I want to stay horny
but you'd still do that we can say
Horner looking at the badge yeah just
look at the bed you have to lose warning
us please don't look at the vege look at
that don't just stare at the vets no
don't look at it stare at it no that's
even worse I like you want to go yeah
damn imagine next level the point has to
be like one of those endoscopy things
where you have to go in there by the way
I've seen it all I've been all the way
up in it and it's nice that's that folks
see you later
it's the Yukon Gold that's my fuller wet
the bed again that's my like home alone
[Music]